how's it going out there Aaron Sampson
here and Ryan Schubert and we want to
talk about World War three and whether
it's gonna upset battlefield 5 this year
battlefield just released their roadmap
and I'm just gonna say that personally
for me it reads like in early access
title a lot of the features that we were
looking forward to aren't gonna be there
at launch and all day enough World War 3
is also just coming out now as an early
access title
it's channeling the spirit of
battlefield 4 if not maybe directly
copying and improving on aspects of it
but a lot of people are interested in
world war 3 and we're trying to figure
out if it has a shot so let's get into
it Ryan
what you tell us how we got here ok so
back in May there was this sort of
string of press events for upcoming
video games and the two big games that
jumped on the sort of pre e3
presentation bandwagon we're a Call of
Duty and Battlefield and both of them
had presentations of their games that
sort of freaked fans out and they were
back to back one week was Call of Duty
the next week was battlefield and on the
following Monday after battlefield the
first announcement trailer for World War
3 dropped and a whole lot of people got
excited because it looked like
battlefield all right so then
battlefield 5 got delayed and World War
3 basically pushed up their early access
to right around the week where
battlefield was supposed to come out
right to try and capitalize on it
more important than all this though is
like is World War 3 a good battlefield
game for lack of a better term I mean I
would say just as a quick short answer
that it is it presses a lot of the
battlefield buttons that battlefield
hasn't been pressing very well I think
if I had to narrow it down to one thing
that I really like about World War 3 is
that I've kind of had this feeling that
battlefield hasn't been quite right for
a while recently I realized that it came
down to the gaming loop the idea of a
gaming loop is where a player is
presented with a challenge it's in every
game a player is presented with a
challenge they have a tool set to solve
that challenge then they beat it or they
don't beat it and they learn something
and ideally they get rewarded
for it it's this continual loop that
happens moment to moment in games it
also happens between matches so a great
example of that is titanfall where you
spawn in you fight the other team you do
great you get your Titan you do more
great work with your Titan and hopefully
you win the match battlefield 5 doesn't
really have that loop because of the
smaller map sizes and the random vehicle
spawns there's no reward for you doing
anything in my opinion anymore yeah
there's the squad commander system but
that's one person in your squad who's
like getting rewarded so basically you
spawn you run somewhere you die you
spawn you run somewhere you die you you
do it over and over again and you never
feel like you're getting your Titan to
drop right so like the tanks are just
sitting in the back of the field and you
have to randomly die at a time when a
tank is randomly spawning and then
randomly hope you have a good round in
that tank and not get killed by an
engineer I think that World War 3 in a
nutshell is doing a much better job at
this loop so they have battle points you
spend those battle points on the tank or
like on the artillery strike or on the
other elements of the game almost like a
little bit of a Call of Duty element to
it it's very similar to the Call of
Duty's scorestreak system but it's not
as aggressively dependent on whether
you're kicking a whole bunch of ass the
game also improves on baltha forward in
certain ways that are really interesting
and moves that the genre forward a bit
like you can choose to get bonus points
for attacking or defending objectives so
you can sit back and choose to defend
and get rewarded for it or you can
choose to go off an attack and get
rewarded for it you know a battlefield
for a long time is kind of strayed away
from the idea of conquest points being
something that you want to stick around
and defend they're just not very
interesting I wholeheartedly approve of
this approach one of my biggest gripes
about battlefield for a long time now is
that conquest capture points aren't
worth holding for any reason you can go
back to some older versions of
battlefield where if you were holding
that point you would have artillery you
might have an airfield that was
squatting planes there might be a tank
spawn there there might be a real reason
to hold that position and in recent
versions of battlefield it's basically a
ditch
or next to a bridge or something that
really is just a place to sit for 30
seconds while you wait for a timer to go
off and World War 3 isn't that different
on that respect but its system of you
know capturing two points to get points
instead of one single location there's
like a binary location capturing and
having that system where if you choose
to be a defending player you get more
points by defending I think that's
really smart
to like sort of shape the game into a
more strategic battle now a lot of the
points that you are talking about are
the best analogy I can use is the way
that blackout is sort of best hits of
Call of Duty environments I will say
this games a bit derivative and many of
the places that you go you'll recognize
they feel like they're inspired by
operation Metro there's a garage under
one of the maps that looks like it was
from the close quarters DLC these days
are heavily inspired by great elements
of great battlefield maps
but these maps are huge and there's so
many routes through them up and over
them they're large and there's always
ways you can attack objectives
differently which is something that I
really like in a battlefield game with a
relatively high player account there was
always this sort of chance that your
squad you're just four or five guys
could go and take an objective on the
other side of the map or go and sort of
harass an objective on the other side of
the map while the main team was taking
over like a position centrally located
this with its roots and different ways
to sort of sneak around really does
bring back the opportunity for that kind
of gameplay I think also you know with
the size of the map and the type of
gameplay you're talking about all the
enough World War three also gets the RPG
tank balanced today that battlefield has
been kind of getting away from like I
remember in the battlefield alpha and
beta
if you've lucked into a tank you could
oftentimes get destroyed by an engineer
before you even knew that they were
there the RPG tank fights in this are
better because they typically take place
at longer ranges they're more
cat-and-mouse it takes three or four
hits and sometimes you run out of ammo
before you can kill it tanks can also go
to the back of the map and heal up so it
feels like the older balanced versus I
don't know like everything you so sped
up these days and in battlefield in a
way that I just don't find to be
compelling anymore one of the things I
like about this game so far is the
weapon customization and loadout options
it's similar to insurgency in that it's
based on weight and at least at this
point in the in the early access
everything is available to you so you
don't have to unlock things you can just
go in there and modify the weapons the
way you want them plug them in to your
loadout and it'll just be dependent on
how encumber do you want to be and that
really gives you a lot of freedom to
decide how you want to play the game and
what kind of sort of tactical player you
want to be rather than being dependent
on unlocks the way battlefield has
become so tedious with unlocking I
really like these games that are sort of
treating you more like an adult on that
level you're treated like you can figure
out what you want and you're gonna have
those toys available to you right away
so I don't want to make this all sound
too cheery because World War 3 does have
some aspects that it definitely lags
behind battlefield on it cannot touch
frostbite when it comes to destruction
sound design I would say is bad I agree
with that the sound design needs
significant improvement I know it's
early access but if they're gonna pour a
resource into something I would put in a
sound because we saw how effective sound
is in insurgency
a game that has probably has the best
sound that I've heard in a long time and
it makes a huge difference in how you
perceive that game it absolutely does
like the you know the graphics are
probably a little bit better in World
War 3 but insurgency the sound really
transports you to the environment and
the sound is definitely lacking in World
War 3
there's also issues that they're gonna
have to work out with spawn killing or
bad spawn placements battlefields come a
long way on their danger spawn system
and trying may be successful sometimes
not others to get you spawning in places
where you don't instantly die even if
they're not doing it perfectly there you
can tell that they care about it you
know the dangerous planning thing was
actually one of the best decisions they
made in a long time in that game then
there's just your average bugs from an
early access title like tanks flying off
into the sky when you get into them
falling through the map you know the
usual stuff you'll find from a game
that's early on I agree that it's
important to keep this in the context of
early access it's a little bit buggy it
takes a while to get into a match I was
finding that when I would create a
custom loadout it wouldn't save between
sessions of the game so there's there's
definitely these things that show that
it is not completely polished and has a
ways to go it's currently $28 for an
early access title and they're gonna
start adding Maps as they go
battlefields full price we don't really
know fully what's gonna be there at
launch this roadmap I think was supposed
to be a good thing but I kind of read it
as in most of the game I was expecting
to be there won't be there at launch and
look we could be wrong
we've played an alpha and a beta and
I've also played through three of the
war stories or at least portions of
three war stories so I honestly can't
say that after all that I feel like I
have a good grasp of what exactly
battlefields gonna feel like at launch
but right now the way it's been marketed
and from what I've seen it feels more
like an early access title I know that
might sound a little harsh and will of
course give it a fair shake but at the
end of the day world war 3 has a shot of
peeling off people who want a modern
shooter who miss battlefield 3 and 4 who
aren't super into the world war 2
setting for either mechanical or other
reasons and who want to stick with a
game that's being developed Ryan do you
think World War 3 has a shot against the
battlefield this year I think it
deserves a shot
like it as you said it is derivative we
are returning to basically trodden
territory but it does sort of feel like
that game if you miss the modern
battlefields it's kind of got that tone
to it you know as soon as you spawn in
and it's raining and it's dark and it's
gloomy it's almost like being back and
you know Grand Bazaar or to run highway
or something like that like it it
captures some of that feeling and I
haven't felt that in a little while in a
battlefield game alright well we'll just
have to see World War 3 is currently out
in early access and battlefield 5 is out
next month so we'll follow up once we
get our hands on battlefield 5 and of
course we'll have a full review for you
on gamespot comm thanks for watching let
us know how you feel about the two games
in the comments below are you playing
World War 3 do you like it or is it kind
of too rough around the edges for you
and you're looking for that more
polished battlefield experience I'd
really like to know what people think
because we had a lot of excitement
around the trailers but now that people
have their hands on it
I really want to know make a break time
alright thanks for watching
you